i'm gonna cut up our bed sheets right
now i'm sure kelly won't mind at all
she's just gonna come home and find me
and she's gonna be like what are you
doing i'm gonna say hi
and moon night
i'm defender of the night did you
spanish they're all smoking slowly backs
out tries to get the dog to come with
her
yeah that's that's how it goes here at
our home welcome back to new rock stars
marvel's moon night is coming at the end
of this month giving us a fresh look at
the dapper mr knight identity who is
this guy compared to the other
identities we've met and how do they all
connect to
god
[Music]
we're working on it we are working we
have a month we have a month to lock in
on how we're going to kick off each of
these we were doing that at the same
time i was like wait is that an eric
figaro
who knows at this point who knows what
any of this is
this is inside marvel and we are back on
wednesdays in anticipation for moon
night coming to disney plus march 30th
when this will become our official moon
night after show i'm eric voss with me
is mt eric i don't know if you've ever
heard the wolf cry to the uh to a blue
corn moon but i have never seen a wolf
cry to a
a red adorned moon knight covered in the
blood of his enemies which i'm very
excited for
in a month
[Laughter]
wow you know we were talking about
pocahontas earlier here at new rockstars
and mt found a way to get pocahontas
into a video i'm so proud of you i just
had that on my mind i was like i'm just
gonna say it why not
you did and it worked so at the stroke
of midnight on march 1st disney released
a poster for the moon knight identity
who might be the most interesting of
this bunch mr knight and we're gonna
explain why this guy is so cool and when
it comes to steven grant mark spector
jake lockley the vigilante moon knight
mr knight might actually steal this show
depending on exactly
how they're gonna depict him what voice
they'll be using how he'll fit into this
plot and uh how many more moon knight
identities might still be under wraps
you know because he pulled back one of
those mummy wraps he got a whole other
moon knight russian doll under there i
hope that uh mr knight's voice is just
inexplicably uh cleveland brown from
family guy
hey it's mia mr knight
might be a bit off-putting
or just what we need
or just what the show will need
well uh before we talk about moon night
uh it's not marvel related but it is
marvel adjacent because the batman is
coming out this week and we are so
excited for it to hear new rock stars we
can't wait to make some videos about it
our friends at epic hero shop have a new
latest obsession limited edition shirt
for the batman it's an incredible
looking shirt with a cool artful design
and it's not going to be around for long
they're no way home and they're shung
cheese shirts sold out pretty quick so
you should grab one of these quick
before it is sold out now what is our
question as we dive into the month of
moon night mt well bro we gotta ask who
is mr knight exactly because we got that
photo and it looks like so good such a
good it's pretty good adaptation of mr
knight for the comics literally straight
off the page like i think i saw a tweet
from the artist that created mr knight
he was like this is blowing my mind i
love it yeah so mr knight is a form moon
knight takes in war analysis run of the
moon knight comics in 2014 initially
that was moon night volume seven whereas
the hooded moon knight in the white
mummy wrappings is a more violent
vigilante persona mr knight wears a
finely tailored suit with a form-fitting
mask adorned with a crescent moon on the
forehead i love how in this case they
included this stitched seam down the
middle of the mask
to evoke his fractured identity but also
just reminds me at least of how jim
henson would construct his puppets to
have a seam going right down the middle
of their heads which in this case could
also be a way of showing how all of mark
spector's identities are puppeted by a
deeper force that deeper force being
khanshu because this uh all the
different versions of uh mark spector
stephen grant jake lockley their uh
ideas their voices that were in his head
to begin with but they were not
activated until konshu awakened each of
these things so they're coming from this
demonic place which is just fascinating
every time you see one step or one word
spoken or taken by any of these guys
it's all coming from a puppet master
that is now nestled deep in his identity
personality wise mr knight is certainly
less violent more of a genius
criminologist consultant to the police
and crime scenes he's kind of like a
sherlock holmes figure or i guess since
it's so easy to compare moon knight to
batman he is the world's greatest
detective aspect of that vigilante
identity so when we imagine what voice
oscar isaac might use for mr knight we
know that for stephen grant he's going
to use a lower class london accent
because the show is changing the
billionaire stephen grant from the
comics and to instead have steven grant
be a clumsy museum gift shop employee
meanwhile mark spector is likely to be
the past mercenary explorer who got into
this mess to begin with so i would
imagine oscar isaac's like poe dameron
swagger there right
now we haven't really heard from jake
lockley yet but i imagine oscar's just
gonna do his best new york cabbie
archetype for jake you know hey hey i'm
driving here
um and then as moon knight oscar's
probably just going to do his low raspy
batman voice probably with some notes of
egyptian in there too i would wonder um
so that leaves mr knight who to contrast
those other identities might have more
of a classic film noir detective kind of
voice that uh that trans-american
hollywood voice like austin wells or
humphrey bogart you know of all the
fragile minds and all the egyptian ruins
and all the world konchu walks into mine
that's that's kind of what i'm at least
imagining uh because that's like the one
thing that would really set it apart and
and just make him kind of a goofy but
awesome character that we immediately
connect with
uh because all of these disney plus
shows in different ways seem to be uh
evoking certain tropes from uh hollywood
past or from um television past the way
wand division was really just a love
letter for sure the history of american
sitcoms uh loki seemed to be this uh
like douglas adams 1970s kind of retro
sort of vibe uh and then hawkeye had
this whole like uh shane black
lethal weapon uh die hard type christmas
action comedy so i wonder if moon knight
might be due might be doing something
similar um but
what i like thinking about is the
potential conflict between these two
sides of oscar isaac's identity like you
have moon knight who wants to work
outside the law and deliver justice with
his fists whereas mr knight probably
wants to cooperate with law enforcement
but really just to be the smartest
detective in the room to satisfy his own
ego so i want to ask you into which of
these two forms because we don't
normally see both of these forms being
the moon knight identity it's usually
one or the other which of these two do
you think will win out as a dominant
identity by the end of these six
episodes you know what i just think on a
on a purely practical level the mr
knight suit and like the whole getup is
a lot easier for oscar isaac to put on
and to just like move around in and like
to fight in like normally so like i just
feel like mr knight
will probably end up being more
prominent and will probably end up be
seeing mr knight the mr knight persona
in more like cameos moving forward in
the mcu rather than like having oscar
isaac like deck or decked out in like
the full moon night costume because i'm
i'm sure that likes like a pin they
asked to put on and like move around and
all that stuff because i and honestly mr
knight is just so interesting as a
character he's just so suave and he's
just like you know i know everything
basically yeah i i think that
both hopefully will continue to uh play
important roles going forward but you
got to imagine like of the two the
bigger ego it's probably mr knight and i
don't know if uh if marvel studios was
serious about adapting moon knight into
a live-action title until this 2014
version of the character was introduced
like whatever uh attachments you love
about uh previous versions of moon
knight and he has been you know very
interesting to explore um in years past
but it's in more recent comics where you
know i think kevin feige and his team
are like no there there's a live action
story to be told in a mini series or a
movie he could be a character that we
see on big screen played by a very
serious actor um so
that's why i imagine that being i think
you're right empty the more practical of
the two but i want them to have like
kind of a
an explosive jekyll and hyde
kind of uh relationship in the same way
that like banner has a jekyll and hyde
relationship with hulk uh or like in a
way that like i would argue
dr strange and wanda have right now you
have the more calculating sherlock
holmesian type figure um who is locked
in this relationship with a with a more
savage id who uh just kind of responds
more instinctively to situations uh and
is far more terrifying in a lot of ways
but not necessarily um more lethal
because they don't always control
uh
control their rage and they can't always
aim it
correctly
but uh i i'm just excited to see both i
think what blows my mind about watching
all this moon night footage empty is how
both of these characters are are
characters that i want to live with and
i want to hang out with i'm just amazed
how both of these characters look great
on screen like they're characters that
yeah i want to spend six episodes with
at least um like compare that it's not
always easy to pull that off even some
of the uh the marvel disney plus stuff
like some not all these characters look
uh that exciting and then usually they
win me over once the episodes get here
but from the get-go like i'm ready to
hang out with this guy they figured it
out you know that's not necessarily an
easy character to adapt the screen
straight from the page like mr nice
right from the page like the the moon
night costume like i was worried about
how they were going to do that in
general but they did a really great job
and like incorporate and making it look
like it was just like sort of like an
artifact in itself like this is like an
old costume and like there's def it's
been worn before and there's definitely
been other moon nights in the past so
like
a really big bang bang-up job on that
like it's like something that you would
have unearthed from a tomb or from a
museum that you could imagine some
warrior in the past wearing but also
something that practically works right
now exactly and uh he he holds his own
against all the other current avengers
even i love how much they incorporate uh
mummified wrappings uh into the costume
and it's all in fact made of like as if
he himself is a mummy and you know by
extension thematically he is dead he
even looks like his symbol and his chest
like crescent is its own separate object
that is being like kept together by the
rapping it's so interesting right a
weapon a weapon that is just suspended
there in the wrappings and almost as if
by using it he might start to unravel
figuratively and literally
his his own essence
so he has to maintain that control and
avoid using this deadly weapon as much
as he can
there's just so much uh a clever uh
theme layers input
so many literal layers into both of
these costumes uh they could just be
real simple or cosplay
looking but they aren't they're they're
designed with very fascinating craft in
ways that
i don't think we've seen on any of the
marvel disney plus shows i mean one
division had some brilliant brilliant
costumes
but even we see wanda maximoff in her
scarlet witch costume headed into
multiverse of madness they had to kind
of upgrade it they had to tweak it a
little bit i mean vision had some
amazing design i think vision's coolest
cosplay look is honestly zombie vision
right just that huge crater in his head
it's terrifying the glacier eyes
um
so yeah i mean loki had some some really
cool character design but that's like
mostly stuff from the comics the the i i
was a little underwhelmed by by kang's
wardrobe or he remains wardrobe like i
liked watching the behind-the-scenes
loki um documentary
they talked about how they designed
different components of he who remains
wardrobe to be from different geographic
and historical eras and i was like oh
cool i didn't see any of that in that
episode all i saw was just kind of like
the colors that looked vaguely kang like
from the comics
um
yeah but i'm more excited by jonathan
major's performance than i am by how
they dressed them up and what jonathan
majors might do next a lot of that was
also just the lighting they they dimmed
it all in this deep blue and indigo
tones so it was just kind of hard to
make out some of those details um and i
was just so captivated by his monologue
and the things he was saying that i
honestly didn't really care what he was
wearing marvel it's been it's been a
spell uh it's been a bit
a minute since marvel has really wowed
us with a costume
i feel like i'm forgetting something
right i mean like we did get like the
the amazing captain america suit from
falcon winter soldier which was dope but
yeah
i guess that was fine right
it was fine i like how they fused it
with falcon and it looked pretty
practical yeah um
but it yeah yeah okay i hear you i hear
you i honestly feel like with with wanda
like in one division like that final
scarlet witch costume like we could have
done a like a little bit more
of an effort to make it look more
like ancient because it looks too modern
and like again this could just
definitely be modern wanda's
interpretation of the costume because it
looks way too nice like that's like yeah
that looks like a fashion major to sweat
to town like modern but like i would
love it if it was just more like witchy
and like more like you know like the
salem times like like what agatha wears
essentially yeah i think agatha's
costume in one vision was fantastic
amazing and it looked just like the
comics but it actually looked kind of
scary like catherine hahn looked pretty
creepy with her hair floating her hands
turning black with the pendant with the
the way that she just owned it like
that was that was pretty great i think
that's up there for sure i think i just
like horror costumes is what it is yeah
we like
we like scary women
scare me
we got to talk more about moon knight's
future
the potential of him joining the
avengers because that's what his
showrunner said a quote this week but
before we get to that we want to thank
some people who sponsored this episode
starting with our friends at bespoke
post this winter upgrade your daily
routine with bespoke post in their new
seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections bespoke post
partners with small businesses and
emerging brands to bring you the most
unique goods every month producer zach
wears a cool cardigan that he got from
bespoke post he wears that every day no
matter what your into box of awesome has
you covered from winter cocktails to
cozy threads and camping gear essentials
box of awesomeness collections for every
part of your life there's nothing like
the fun of opening the box with a cool
new pocket knife or a cocktail shaker to
get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime each box is
valued at around 70 but you only have to
pay a fraction of that price plus with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small business get twenty percent off
your first monthly box when you sign up
at box of awesome dot com and enter the
code marvel at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com code marvel for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com code
marvel we also want to thank expressvpn
for sponsoring this episode because how
did you choose which internet service
provider to use most of us have very
little choice because isps are kind of
like monopolies in the regions they
serve they use this monopoly power to
take advantage of customers data caps
streaming throttles the list goes on and
on but worst of all many isps log your
internet activity and then sell that
data to other big tech companies or
advertisers so to prevent isps from
seeing my gross internet activity i
protect all of my devices with
expressvpn expressvpn is a simple app
for your computer or smartphone that
encrypts all of your network data and
then tunnels it through a secure vpn
server so that your isps cannot see any
of your activity that's the reason we
recommend expressvpn as the best way to
hide your online activity from your isp
you just download the app tap one button
on your device and you are protected we
love how easy it is to use and be
protected and expressvpn does not slow
your connection that's why it's rated
the number one vpn service by business
insider and the verge so stop handing
over your personal data to isps and
other tech giants who mine your activity
and sell off your information protect
yourself with the vpn i trust to keep me
private online visit expressvpn.com
marvel that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
marvel to get three extra months for
free go to expressvpn.com
marvel right now to learn more and we
want to thank helix sleep for sponsoring
this episode mt and i have to be on our
a-game during inside marvel recording
sessions we can't afford to have a bad
night of sleep because of a crappy
mattress that's why we love our helix
mattresses helix sleep has a quiz that
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers i
have a helix mattress and i love it mt's
helix mattress is getting delivered soon
so he will report back on how much he
loves it in some future episodes i want
a full report empty oh boy
i'm gonna test it thoroughly that sounds
weird not never bad never
test it with a friend test it by
yourself it's all okay the mattress
ships right to your door for free no
need to go to a mattress store just go
to helixsleep.com inside marvel take
their two-minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they'll have a 10-year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll be big enough for you
if you don't love it but you will helix
is offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com inside
marvel all right back to moon night so
empty this week jeremy slater who's a
show writer on moon knight told total
film that he intends moon knight to join
the avengers he said quote look if it
was up to me he would be part of the
avengers it's absolutely not up to me
but i think that's the goal
so i want to ask you emt what would it
look like how could moon knight fit into
the current avengers lineup that we know
well you know moon knight is a huge
brawler dude and we need a hardcore
brawler on the team um especially after
you know the unfortunate loss of black
widow and obviously moon knight cannot
replace natasha romanoff but like
bro we the avengers need someone that's
not afraid to pull their punches natasha
only pulled her punches with clint
during civil war but that's about it she
feels like a hardcore brawler so i think
that having moon knight join the team
could help in that aspect but also he's
also tied to the you know this to gods
in the supernatural aspect of the mcu
which we're moving forward into
depending on how
the whole celestial thing goes with um
the celestials grabbing the eternals to
see how earth is doing we might need um
some type of representatives on the god
side um
on behalf of humanity to just represent
like gods and so i think that moon
knight will be able to be like oh um
this is what konchu has to say um about
like this type of thing being that
connection to the the god realm other
than thor cause like thor is often the
cosmos doing his thing so like we need
like a person on earth um that's gonna
you know connect us to the god realm so
like i think it's gonna be moon knight
but how do you think moon is gonna fit
yeah i think moon knight specifically
for his connections to the supernatural
for the dark demonic side of the of the
mcu going forward uh because we do have
shang chi fitting in on the avengers
lineup he's a pretty good hand-to-hand
fighter right i'd love to see those two
van gogh uh go into the ring um but you
know when it comes to people who are
just really good fighters until secret
wars i don't know how useful they're
gonna be for huge mystical threats and
what's happening in thor love and
thunder that's i think the challenge you
know you have to kind of let people stay
on their own battlefronts and fight wars
as best as they can um but i think
secret wars is gonna be fascinating to
see all these people in in an arena
together
however but yeah as you were saying the
more the mcu expands into the
supernatural in the in the dark
uh
scary sides of this world moon knight's
going to be very very helpful i mean we
do have the the sorcerers you have huang
uh you have dr strange
they
i think they have a pretty keen
understanding of what's out there but i
think they're now exploring more into
the multiverse things from other
dimensions uh but there are
there's plenty of demonic threats in the
mcu and i think the more we explore
agave house of harkness in the history
of the dark hold with cod
i i think moon knight is going to be the
the person that you go to for some
advice i also just like i don't know if
we've seen in the mcu like a really
great detective like tony stark and iron
man 3 had uh some pretty good detective
skills
uh explored but since then you know we
don't really see people working with
with law enforcement and investigating
crimes i think mr knight could be really
helpful in that world i i want to see
that that part of the world explored
especially how depending how dr strange
the multiverse of madness ends and like
what if it ends with like with more dark
creatures introduced into new york that
need you know that are messing with the
people of new york and that need you
know your mr knight to to help them out
like in a sort of dr strangey type way
so like for sure i agree with you
completely i also feel like there is
there's this possibility here uh given
the way that a spider-man far from home
ended with nick fury going out into
space and we learned from spider-man no
way home that nick fury has been off
earth for a year and in front from when
we learned that there are a couple
avengers were like occupied for some
reason what if
the actual avengers the og whatever's
left of the team
has gone on into space and like a new
avengers team will be formed to protect
earth while these avengers were gone
because like new figures probably like
you know what nothing bad's gonna happen
like there's a bigger threat out of
space let's go avengers and so like you
have your your moon knights and then
you're you're miss marvels and like
you're you're young avengers coming
together like we're the new avengers
because there's no avengers here and
we're the only people left
um because like that happens that's a
big point in um i think the infinity
comic series um right before like the
whole secret wars thing popped off where
like there was two avengers teams sort
of defending earth on two fronts like
there's one team on earth one team in
space so it would be really cool with uh
the mcu adapted that for sure
i think you're right mt i think there's
gonna be at least two i really think
there's gonna be a lineup i just don't
know that every single team should be
called the avengers i think they should
have different names like we already
have the guardians of the multiverse
that we saw in what is we have the
avengers um which at this point do we
need to have a group called the avengers
i get you know for marketing reasons
it's helpful but it's helpful
but like to be avengers you need
something to avenge like in the marvel
comics the avengers are one of many
groups you have the x-men you have the
illuminati you have the midnight suns
you have the fantastic four like there's
oh
the avengers is not the most interesting
team i would argue that we see guardians
of the galaxy
is a far more interesting team yes we
should have the avengers but i'm more
interested to see what uh moon knight
would do on like the midnight suns oh
for sure played with doctor strange with
the yeah because then he could be more
gritty in like those darker like
midnight suns type of projects than you
know an avengers project for sure right
for sure uh well that will be it for
this week of inside marvel but we're
gonna be talking a lot of moon night
this month or whatever the biggest
marvel story is until we get there but i
cannot wait for march 30th uh march and
april and early may are going to be a
very exciting time and then uh sometime
after that we'll get more information
about when um miss marvel's gonna come
out she-hulk secret invasion it's gonna
be a very very uh big couple months for
marvel from there march is going to be a
big month for fighting vengeance let me
tell you buddy yes it will be
don't forget to check out our great
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
at ea boss follow mt and mastertainment
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
and good night and good luck lee
nailed it
foreign